my name is Jane Chueh, and I'm a clinical professor at
the Stanford Medical School, Medical Center. clinically, I work as a high
risk obstetrician which means we see high risk pregnancies, and I also do
fetal ultrasounds on pregnancies in general, looking for fetal anomalies.
>> What kind of, what makes a pregnancy at-risk or high risk?
>> well,
you know, every pregnancy deserves close scrutinization, right? And
so we look at every pregnancy as if there
could be something going on. And so we, at
every ultrasound, we do that, particularly at the five
month ultrasound, where we carefully go through the fetal
anatomy. And so sometimes, even if you're 20 years
old, things can happen that are unexpected and rare.
we look at every fetus with that sort of light.
There are other, other, you know, types of conditions that the mother can have
that predispose them to being high risk. And some of those are if you're
older, if you have diabetes, for example
or some sort of, underlying medical issue
like hypertension. So those things are, all play into our our pool of high risk.
>> Sure. Now we've talked a lot in our
lesson up to this point about how important the ABO
blood type is for on our red blood cells. and I'm curious
to know how blood type affects, possibly these regular or high risk pregnancies.
>> So every patient that we see, we do require, that
we know their blood type and RH type and I know
you are talking a lot about the ABO blood system. it's
important because at delivery there is a chance that they may bleed,
whether they have a vaginal delivery or whether they have
a c-section. sometimes they bleed, most of the time they
bleed very minimally, and so they don't require transfusion but
occasionally in rare cases, they have a lot of bleeding. and
it becomes a very complicated case where they require lots
of blood. if you need blood, then it's important to have
the type of blood that the person receives match to
their type. So we, we want to know what that is and
in fact we actually require that they be
typed twice. So they're typed at a prenatal visit
and they are also typed when they come
in before they receive blood. So there's two that,
>> Is that important?
>> That, that is important because you can't just could, it could be
a mistake, I mean if one, if they had just one result. So
the, the policy is that, there's
two that actually correlate that, that they'rere
the same, If you don't have a blood type then, and you need blood
then the only option is, you know, the
blood bank gives you universal donor, which would
be O negative. but O negative is not the most common type of blood there is, and
you know, you can't use up your entire pool of O negative blood. So, the best
thing would be to, you know, give the
person the type of blood that they actually have.
>> Actually have a match.
>> Yes.
>> Now, you mentioned the ABO type is important.
But you mentioned another factor, a positive or negative factor?
>> Yes.
>> Tell us about that.
>> So in pregnancy,
particularly the RH factor which is a rhesus blood group on the red cell is, is
important. this refers to a group of antigens,
the most common being the D antigen. And there's
a D positive group, and there's a D
negative antigen in other words you know, or say
they're missing the D antigen. So everybody has
two alleles, right? So there, they could be D
positive, D positive or D positive, D negative or D negative D negative.
>> So it's kind of like, the O type where
O is nothing, whereas you have A, B or nothing.
>> Correct, exactly, exactly. So, just like with A blood
type, you can have homozygous A, which be A positive
A positive, or a heterozygous A, which would be A
plus O, A plus O. Right? Or AO. the rhesus group
also is the same thing, so you can have D plus
D plus, which would be homozygous D plus, or you can have
D plus D negative, which would be heterozygous D plus, or
you can have D negative. Which would be D negative, D negative.
>> Right. And we'll learn a lot more about dominance, actually in one of
our lessons, lesson 5. Where we'll learn
that, the D plus allele, then is dominant?
>> Right, right.
And so this becomes an issue when, we find an
Rh negative woman whose D negative, D negative. so if she,
marries a partner, who is not Rh negative.
In other words, he's Rh positive and he's
either D plus D plus or D plus D negative, both of them of which are considered
you know, D or Rh positive. then there's a chance that her child could be RH
positive, either D plus, well actually it would
have to be 100% D plus D negative, right?
>> Right.
>> Because one of the genes comes from her
and it'll be D negative and the other one
is going to come from her partner. So we need
to know what her partner's genotype is, for the Rh
antigen. And we need to know if the fetus
has, you know, 100% chance of being Rh positive.
Which this fetus would have if the father was
homozygus, Rh positive. In other words, he had two copies
of the D gene. that would obviously result in a fetus that's
heterozygous, Rh positive. However, if the father is heterozygous and
he's D plus, D negative, then there's a chance that her
fetus will be Rh negative, which would be D minus, D minus.
>> And so just to be clear here then, the risk here is that the mother
would be Rh negative and the baby's Rh positive.
>> Correct.
>> And if the mother's and the baby's blood were to see each other, that the
mother's blood might not recognize the Rh positive
in the baby's blood and attack it or something?
>> No, no, basic, if the mother's Rh negative and
sees the Rh positive in the fetus, in the fetus
blood, fetal blood, then it will recognize it as being
formed. Because she's never seen the D antigen until she
became pregnant, right?
>> So what happens when that, so let's say you,
you know, the scenario happens. What, what, what, what happens next?
>> Right. So what happens is if that happens, then
her antibody screen will come back positive, that she has an
antibody. So that antibody would be against her fetus's D
antigen, which is foreign to her and small titer is not
an issue, but with over time the body has
a memory. Snd so over time, it will mount a
higher and a higher response. So, for example, usually
the first pregnancy, the titers don't get to a point
where they're concerning or that they will actually destroy
the fetal, fetal blood. Because if, once the mother makes
so much antibody against the fetus, the, the antibodies
will cross and they will actually hemolyze the fetal blood.
It'll attack, it'll attack the red cells because
of the foreign antigen on the fetal blood.
>> Mm-hm. So essentially what, what you're telling us is that, initial, so
let's say a mother is having her first pregnancy and she's Rh negative, she's
D negative and the baby's D positive. Even though she may have some antibodies
that might attack it, because it's her
first pregnancy there aren't that many antibodies.
>> Correct.
>> So it wouldn't be so bad, but maybe in her
second or third pregnancy, she's have a lot more of those antibodies.
>> Right. Exactly. Those antibiotics.
>> Exactly.
>> I see.
>> So the first pregnancy,
what we do is we find out that she's sensitized. That's what the
word is, you know, when, when we find that she has antibodies already
made against the D antigen. And we follow those titers of those antibodies
and there's a critical titre above which we, then we start to get worried.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So as long as she's below that critical titre, then we
just follow monthly with blood titers from her. Once she rises above that,
then we have to start thinking, okay, is this mother going to mount,
is, is she mounting such a high response that it's causing fetal anemia?
And we actually have ways of looking for fetal anemia.
The old fashioned way was to put a needle into
the pregnancy sac, take out fluid and check for bilyruben,
which is a breakdown product of hemolysis, right? And there's
graphs, this curve called the Liley Curve, which you'd plot
the points and, based on the gestational age. You'd find
out whether there's a normal amount of bilirubin or an
abnormal amount, which would indicate a high amount of hemolysis.
Well, that was invasive and, you know, people would
end up having multiple amniocenteses over the pregnancy, course of
the pregnancy. And it wasn't that long ago, because when
I trained, that was the way we treated sensitized pregnancies.
But now, there's a non invasive way of monitoring
for fetal anemia, where we use ultrasound, to look at
the blood flow in the fetal brain. And what we
do is we measure the peak velocity in the middle
cerebral artery of the fetus. And we can tell whether
the fetus is anemic, based on the velocity of flow.
>> If, so then if, if they're anemic it, it slows?
>> It goes up actually.
>> It actually goes up?
>> Yeah. So because, if you're anemic, what you're trying to
do is you're trying to preserve flow to your most important
organs and obviously, the brain is the most important. So, it
shunts blood there and you'll have a higher velocity. So that's how,
and then we have these elaborate curves now.
That based on the flow the peak velocity
in the middle, cerebral artery, we can tell,
what the chances that this fetus has anemia.
>> Wow.
>> So, if it's high chance, you know, we might just skip
the whole amniocentesis, and we usually do now, we don't go without, because
it's so predictive. We just go in and we sample the fetal
cord to check the hematocrit rate. And if it's low, then we transfuse.
So we actually get in there, we're ready to transfuse.
and we used O negative blood for the fetus, that is
matched to the mother's, to make sure there's no antibodies
that the fetus can't handle. And we check the keratin, but
we usually have a idea where it might be and
there's these charts that, so, if we find out the hematocrit
is 10 or 15, then we know how much to
transfuse. And then, we check the keratin, and if it's 10,
then we know we have to give this many CC's of blood.
>> So, what are besides the actual
mother mother-fetus interaction, are there any other
important clinical settings related to this or
otherwise, where knowing blood type's very important?
>> just the first one, you know for the mother, mostly for her
safety, if she hemorrhaged during pregnancy
or delivery, that she would need blood.
>> And there are times when I
guess, patients need a lot of blood, or a little
bit of blood? I mean is there ever, is there ever
been a scenario where you're like, oh gosh, I need this
type of blood but you know, I don't have enough or.
>> Yes.
>> what do you do?
>> So, it yeah, we have something called massive
transfusion protocol. this happens when
there's obstetrical hemorrhage disaster that
happens. usually, if you have time, you try to give
matched blood, and you know the, the person's blood type.
Especially if you've anticipated the possibility, and she's already
been crossed and matched. but, if not, then you know,
you activate the protocol and you give O negative blood.
And, and we've had cases where due to certain conditions
of the placenta and the uterus, especially one called the
placenta accreta. Where the placenta grows into the uterus, where
you can't remove the placenta after delivery. We have to
remove the entire uterus and there's so much blood flow,
that they, the mothers lose so much blood they
can receive, you know, 50 to 100 units of blood.
>> what would be the reaction, I'm just curious, if
the wrong blood type was administered? what happens to the patient?
>> so they can have a transfusion reaction, which we'll need
to look up in a book, I mean, I'm, I know,
I know what it's like but it's, basically, they get very,
very sick, you know? It, it, they get high fevers, they
I think they start hemolyzing, basically. All of their blood cells, you know.
And, I know that we can, there's a, there's a mild transfusion reaction,
where you can prevent a little bit of that by giving some pre-medication.
But then, if it's truly unmatched blood, then, you, you could die from that.
>> Well, that raises just sort of I guess
an interesting question. Do you know your blood type?
>> I do.
>> Oh.
>> it's B positive, but I don't
remember the scenario, I've never received blood.
I think I just asked my parents one time and
they knew, but we have people coming all the time and
they don't know. We, we do a procedure and we
need to know their blood type. Oh so, here's another, another
scenario we need to know their blood type. I forgot to mention, if you're
RH negative, so we can't obviously type
every single RH negative person, you know, what their fetus
is, because you don't want to invasively go in there and check.
We also don't need to, to check every father and unless there was some sort of
issue. So for all of the, sort of, the general RH negative women, they receive
something called RhoGAM during pregnancy. RhoGAM is an
immuno-globulin that blocks the antigens on the red
cells. So, if you might imagine the fetal
cell trying to get into the maternal circulation.
if it got in there the RhoGAM would just attach itself to all
the sites, bind all the sites, so the mother can't see the antigens.
>> That's clever.
>> And, you can't, she won't amount, she won't mount to response.
So that way, if the fetus happened to be RH positive, I
mean, RH positive, that's correct, then she won't see the positive, D
antigen. And so that's what we use RhoGAM for. RhoGAM is given in
the middle of pregnancy, around 28 weeks, on all R Rh negative
women, just by the chance of perhaps, that fetus might be Rh positive.
>> How many are Rh negative in general?
>> So about 5% of the Caucasian
population in the United States, are Rh negative.
>> I see.
>> So they receive RhoGam at 28 weeks, and also after delivery if the fetus,
or the newborn now, obviously after delivery, is RH
positive. So that she doesn't mount a response you
know, by, because during, during the delivery process there's
some mixing of blood between the fetus and the mother.
>> So, and you mentioned now, so, I
guess we've learned about ABO and sort of this
new antigen RH. Are there other antigens on
the red blood cells that we care about too?
>> Yes. Actually, there's two pages, very small print, of other antigens
that are on the red cell antigen, on the red blood cell. And some of them, the
most common one is kell. Kell for it's, it's
not common, because, as, it's most of the population is
Kell negative. So, it's only an issue if the
mother has somehow received blood from a Kell positive person, and then she saw
that as being. Foreign as she mounted the,
Kell antibody, right? Because most people are Kell-negative and
they meet a Kell-negative person and the reproduce and
there's no issue because there's compatibility. but if you
happen to be Kell-negative and have the antibody, then
that could be an issue because your fetus. Could
be Kell-negative and you know, you could suffer, the
fetus could suffer from that. So, again, we go
through the same thing of monitoring for fetal anemia
if the mother is has the antibodies to Kell.
>> So it sounds like even in pregnancy and
even otherwise knowing your blood types could be really important.
>> So, we do have people come in for procedures that, like
amniocentesis, and if they're RH negative and they're not sensitized. They have
no antibodies, and we don't want them to be sensitized, so they
would get RhoGam. So we do need to know their blood type and
their RH type for that reason. We don't really need
to know the ABO at that point because we're not
giving blood. But we really need to know their Rh
type because if they're Rh negative they would get RhoGam.
most people don't know their blood type. I
don't know that, that's a critical thing, you
know, right this minute. But, obviously, you know,
it, the time of birth or you're going through
some sort of procedure surgically, the hospital would
say oh, you need to be typed. Just in
case, you know there's a significant risk that
you might receive some blood. You should be typed.
>> Great. I, I want to just finish up. I'l love to just hear
a little bit more about your background and how you actually found yourself in
the sort of OB realm of medicine.
>> well, I think like you, in high
school biology, I was really interested in reproductive medicine,
I just thought it was very beautiful, just how,
you know. The life is created and all the
different things that have to go right, in order
to, to create a, a new person. and so
from that intellectual interest I carried that into medical
school. when I did my OB rotation I found
the people who were in OB were very
upbeat and optimistic. And energetic, in general. And
I think, you know, because most of our
outcomes are good, it's not, it's in general
a happy field because we get to see
beautiful babies, and twins, and triplets, and some
quadruplets. So, there all kinds of things, and
yet, there's another component where it's very intense with,
you know, fetal anomalies. Also, high-risk mothers, that have
had bad histories where they've lost pregnancies and they're hoping
to get a good one this time. So, there's a
whole mixture of both happy and yet very intensely, possibly
sada that we feel like we can do. You know,
make a difference with. And so, that's, that's what drew
me to OB. And that's why I like high-risk OB.
Because of the chance to be able to help people
who have not had such a great outcome in the past.
>> How do you see genetics playing a role in the
future of both, you know, OB pregnancy and maybe medicine in general?
>> Well, genetics is really the future, you know, I mean,
it's occurring, and the knowledge that's happening in genetics is occurring
at such an incredible speed. It helps us every single day.
I mean, when we, when we see an ultrasound, we wonder if
this is a genetic thing. We wonder if there's testing
for it. We wonder if we can do it for
maternal blood, or whether we need to do an invasive
procedure to find out what the answer is. So all those
questions, you know, can change from, like, week to week,
and so. It's truly amazing what genetics has, has been
able to offer us. one example I just want to give
you is this Rh group system again. So, in the past,
if the father had the D antigen and could
pass it to the fetus. And we weren't sure if
the fetus had it or not. We would have to
do an invasive procedure. like an amniocentesis. Or something called
[UNKNOWN]
sampling. Which is done in the first trimester. And
that would be, be able to type the fetus's genome
type for our, the Rh, group. in the future,
you know, they're hoping to be able to do this
on maternal blood. And that's a, that's a step
forward in genetics because eventually hopefully, we can avoid having
to do invasive procedures to, to get information. And
already we're moving in that direction. And even with testing
for Down syndrome. It's moved into the, the maternal blood.
So we're doing much fewer and invasive procedures, because of that.
>> So what's the basis behind that? Just really quickly,
is that the fact that there are blood cells from the,
>> Yes, so there are blood, they're actually it's not blood cells around
there, now, we're talking about DNA.
So there's free-floating DNA from the fetus.
>> From the fetus?
>> From the fetus. In the mother's circulation. They were,
for many years, looking for intact cells, but it turns out
intact cells are problematic because they can
last for a long time. They can even
be from a past pregnancy. So, but
free-flowing DNA is very short-lived, or relatively short-lived.
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
hemolytic event.
>> Yes, there' actually some apoptosis, which is a
word meaning cell death. And so these cells that
die. And they're supposed to, you know. They turn
over, release their DNA, and they're found in maternal circulation.
And because of our incre, incredibly technology, we're able
to detect such minute amounts of DNA, and be able
to separate that from the maternal in a very
complicated fashion which I won't go into here. but by
using those techniques, they're able to determine, like for
example, the fetal Rh type by just drawing blood on
the mother. Now, it's not perfect yet. I mean, and
I think a test like this has to be perfect
because you don't want to misdiagnose, for example, and
tell the patient that your fetus is D negative and
it's not at risk. When actually, it was D positive.
So you can't tolerate any mistake right, you can't have
any error in this part. Has to be 100% accurate. So
when it becomes like that then we could possibly, possibly diagnose
[UNKNOWN]
blood. With Down syndrome I think it's already very close
I mean it's something like one in 10,000 risk if
you have a negative test on the blood. Yeah. So
they are able to reduce your risk to a very,
very, very low number based on that. So I think,
you know, genetics is fascinating. That's another reason I went
to high-risk OB, because I really love genetics. I actually
did a genetics fellowship, in addition to my high-risk OB fellowship.
So it was a nice supplement because a lot of it goes hand into hand and
everything you see now in OB and ultrasound,
pre natal ultrasound, is tied into genetics, somehow.
>> Very cool, thank you for what you
do, and for interviewing with us.
>> Oh, my pleasure, my pleasure, thanks a lot.
>> Yeah thanks.
>> Okay.